hey what's up guys my name is jonah
welcome back to my game engine series
so last time we basically more or less
completed our bash render check out that
video if you haven't already we
implemented
the rotating of quads we basically moved
everything to just being
a one by one quad inside a vertex buffer
which we then controlled
via like some matrix transformations
every time we submit something
new into that vertex buffer so now that
we've done all that
i mentioned at the last of la the last
at the end of last episode that we would
now need to move on to something
like something of a stress test for our
bat renderer and this
this doesn't just literally mean a
stress test for the purpose of
performance
because we can i mean we can more or
less like we don't specifically need to
be like concerned about oh we better
like stress test every
everything that we ever make to make
sure it's fast enough i don't like
falling into the trap
of just optimizing optimizing optimizing
without creating anything
because if you think about it the
purpose of this engine is to create
something we want to create some content
we want to
create either a game or maybe like a a
graphics application or a scene
or something like that and if we're
constantly concerned with optimization
we're never gonna going to actually have
a final product that we can show to
people
because it's it's interesting and this
might be a topic for another video to be
honest starting this video is strong
right
but anyway um and this might be like
something a little bit different but
ultimately like as a programmer as
as someone who's who's working on this
technology it's really easy to fall into
the trap of
you know check this out like
this runs really fast it's taking me a
millisecond to render all of this
and then you show it to someone who's
like not a programmer someone who you
probably want to share
your creation with and they're like one
millisecond like yeah
i mean i guess that's fast like all i
can see is what's what
what the person's showing in front of me
right there's no like oh man
you know i optimized that now it's like
you know so many less cpu cycles oh have
you seen the cpu cache
on this it's so good no one cares
no one cares right we're creating this
because we want to
show something that someone can enjoy
hopefully and that is not going to
matter obviously if the performance is
so bad
that we're dropping frames and it's
lagging and they can't interact with it
or it's
glitching or something that's terrible
that ruins the experience but
anyway rant over i didn't mean to start
off the video like that to be honest and
i might
even end up re-recording this probably
not though let's just roll with it you
know
um but i i guess the point is i don't
want to stress test this necessarily for
like
being able to be like hey guys check out
my engine you can render a hundred
thousand quads in three milliseconds
we're not about that and i don't really
want this engine to be about that
um the reason i'm doing this is because
first of all i need to have a good test
set up so that we can see and make sure
at all times
that we haven't broken anything and that
everything is working as expected
as expected meaning that if i leave it
running for five minutes
it's not going to use increasingly more
memory until it crashes or something
like that
meaning that rotated quads and textures
and like
zed flickering for example does not
exist everything like gets rendered
correctly
you know are my quads rotating around
their actual origin point and not around
the origin point of the world which is
something we tested last time it's
important to kind of get all of that
stuff
down and again if you're if you don't
have a good
solid test case set up like for example
what happens if we use more than 32
textures
does it just flush that draw and then
continue on again or do we not see
our 33rd texture or or whatever so
anyway
that is the point of today's episode i
haven't done any work on it at all so
this is all going to be live as if it
was a live stream
um so we're just going to jump in and
we're going to see
how we can construct a good test for our
batch renderer okay so this is
this is basically what we have so far
right we have this kind of this is what
hazel engine looks like we have this
full kind of
scene here we can move around using the
wasd keys and then the scroll wheel
and i think that is about it so that's
great and we're demonstrating a number
of things here which is really
kind of useful i guess first of all
we're demonstrating a texture that is
tiled
if you were to look at the for the
actual base of
and i hate that it moves this over here
but if we take a look at this
inside assets textures we have this
checkerboard texture you can see that
one two three four five six seven eight
we've got eight
cells across but obviously inside hazel
we're rendering a lot more than eight of
these checkerboard kind of cells
across right because we're tiling it
same with this this is actually being
tiled pretty heavily as well probably
the same tiling factor
as this so that's first of all
demonstrating that it's not just
um rendering the entire texture it's
actually like we support tiling which is
good
this texture here is textured but it's
also rotating so this is
us demonstrating that we can draw a
rotated textured quad
this is just a colored quad this is i
guess a non-uniform colored cord meaning
we haven't scaled it uniformly
it's you know hot it's the width is
different than the height
and then we have a rotated color cord
because they flow through different code
paths
a rotated texture quad and a rotated
colored quad
are completely different functions and
we need to test that out
now the the next biggest thing i would
say that we need first of all is
yeah i am interested in the performance
i do want to make sure that we can do
that
but more importantly i want to see how
many chords we can actually render
and whether or not we can control this
kind of limit that we have here if we
scroll up here
we have a max squad limit of 10 000. i
want to be able to play around with that
max limit
and see if i can raise it to a hundred
thousand or lower it to 1000 and see
kind of both the performance
implications of that
but also whether or not our renderer
will successfully flush everything and
start a new batch and start a new draw
call if that were to occur
so let's go ahead and make that happen
so one of the things that i like to do
is
inside our kind of renderer 2d data i'm
going to make another struct called
stats and these are going to be our
statistics and to be honest i'm kind of
trying to avoid
um having like you know uh i guess
shortened variable names and stuff like
that like text or other right texture
in this series it seems and just i guess
for the design of the engine so that's
why i'm writing out statistics and not
stats
but i want a few things so first of all
i want the number of draw calls
so this is interesting because like
ultimately these statistics the way that
statistics should work for a renderer
because people a lot of people get
bogged down in okay but how do i know
when to measure and when to complete
measuring because draw calls right well
obviously if i measure
draw calls every time someone begins and
ends a batch it's always going to be one
and the answer is yes it is always going
to be one because one bash is one draw
call
so usually the way that i like to i like
to write statistics is they are
resettable by the client whenever the
client decides to reset those stats
which makes sense um so in other words
what i'm saying is that
it's up to sandbox it's up to the client
to be like okay
i've completed my like rendering
commands or whatever
and now i want to reset my statistics
because i want to start again
so that's kind of the idea so in other
words inside sandbox 2d
where we actually do all of this
rendering stuff once we finish
everything we're going to reset the
stats or i guess more realistically
we're going to reset the stats here
right because that's kind of like the
beginning of our new frame
okay so that being said um we'll
initialize everything to zero as well we
don't really need to because we'll call
reset but i i still will do this just to
make it look a little bit neater
i want to know the draw calls i want to
know the quads
so quad count we'll say um and then
like everything else i guess we can
calculate from quad count so in other
words
if i want to know um get total
vertex count then that's obviously going
to be quad count
times four right and then something like
you get uh total i don't know do we want
a triangle count i guess not index count
is going to be quad count times six so
all of that stuff is like
we don't really need to create actual
like points of data for it
and in fact you know um draw calls and
quad count is probably all that we need
i mean
again memory usage and stuff like that
we can definitely
figure out from all of this other data
and if we want that kind of finer grain
statistics then maybe
we will do something like that later
okay now that we have the statistics
thing
um i like to make them i don't like to
necessarily add names here
so i'm just going to make it down here
and i'll call this um
stats this we will call stats because
this is called statistics
okay so um now that we have stats i
really want a function called reset
stats
and i'm going to put this at the bottom
just because this isn't something that
we necessarily need for like
distribution versions of hazel
for at least we probably would
definitely want it um but
we'll have a reset stats function and i
guess we'll also need something that
retrieves the statistics which is where
this becomes a little bit
um i'll say annoying because
uh it's inside render a 2d data and we
may have to move it so
i am actually going to move this out
i'll have this inside renderer2d though
because it
yeah it should be i guess we'll have our
stats down here
and i'll put statistics over here okay
so reset stats will return
statistics um oh sorry we'll not return
statistics
we need to write a statistics uh
i guess we'll i guess we'll just have a
we'll just copy it
shouldn't be very big anyway so we'll
have a get stats function
which will just return this
and then we'll have a reset stats as
well so with these two in mind let's go
ahead and create these functions
um uh okay let's just create them
manually
i'm going to go ahead and create them at
the very bottom here because they're not
really that
useful and in fact get stats um yeah
okay
so this will return s data dot stats
this will and let's put these inside the
renderer 2d namespace
and we're going to have stats here
statistics and this will basically just
well we can just make this really simple
and just say that um
s data stats we're going to mem set all
of that to just zero
so mem uh zero and then size of
size of statistics
all right and that's pretty much it okay
so what is the issue here
um we need to make sure that we're in a
namespace okay that's good
so back up here then this becomes
renderer 2d
statistics um and
is that it i think that's it uh
yeah because we've already removed it
from here okay great so we have stats
now
um now we need to actually count the
stats so let's uh first of all take the
memory address of stats so that we can
reset it all to zero
and then let's start our statistic
counting so we
this is just like a little bit of a um
a helper method so we don't that doesn't
really exist neither does
this one right so we or this one i guess
so we have or this one so we have four
of these functions so
when we do this kind of index count
we're also going to at the bottom here
do
s data dot stats draw calls plus plus
okay because
oh sorry what am i doing not draw calls
quads quad count
plus plus because we're drawing a quad
um and we'll do that
everywhere so over here as well and what
we'll do is
we're going to always leave this at the
very bottom because if anything happens
we can say
you know if if statistics or something
like that and i know i spelled that
wrong
statistics sorry i just had to do that
right um if we have you know
we can do stuff like this basically to
compile out stuff if we don't want to
collect statistics so that technically
everything will be faster
which is why i'm putting it uh you know
i'm just kind of
putting it at the bottom we're going to
group them all at the bottom and if we
want to add a macro
like that we can we can do that well not
really a macro more of like an if
like a preprocessor directive to compile
to not compile the code
okay that's it i think for like the
court counting
so let me just double check that because
i've been talking a lot quad count
quad count quad count and
quad count okay cool so what we'll do
is we'll add in the stuff required
for um our draw calls so every time we
do a draw command which is render
command draw indexed for us what we want
to do is basically say
s data dot uh
stats dot draw pulse plus plus
okay so clearly if we reset it every
frame like we want to so over here when
we reset it
when we do hazel renderer 2d
reset stats it's going to
[Music]
it's going to set them all to zero and
then over here if we like begin multiple
scenes or do whatever
clearly it's going to gather all of them
up until until the next time
we reset it also if we try and draw more
quads than we're able to hear
then it will also reset it um because
it's going to have to
flush and redo the thing again which is
actually a good point of us
probably wanting to check that because
it doesn't actually do that right now
um so we did we do need to handle that
edge case because you can see that
um if we try and draw a quad it just it
just does it you know like it just goes
in here
and it actually tries to draw it
actually tries to add to the vertex
buffer but if the vertex buffer is full
that's going to be a huge issue so what
we actually need to do because we'll
overflow the buffer like this kind of
quad vertex buffer pointer
is obviously pointing to somewhere that
should be inside quad vertex buffer base
which has obviously a finite size of max
vertices
times size of quad vertex so if we
overflow that we overflow
the memory there and we're going to
either corrupt our program or crash our
program
depending on you know if we're in debug
mode or release mode so it's going to be
bad
um so we definitely need to handle that
so let's just handle that now i think
it's not particularly difficult so every
time we draw something
which is like over here um the first
thing we really need to do
uh is basically um and we can do that
like
i guess i'll do that should i have i'll
have the constants maybe uh i'll do
i'll do that as the first thing so
basically the idea is
that if we have drawn right we can go by
this index count if we really want to
um if we have drawn uh if
if s data quad index count is
greater than our max index count so max
indices
right um well we can probably do greater
than or equal to but if we
think about it since this is times six
and we increase it at the bottom we
should be over it
so if this is greater than max indices
and max indices lives inside
renderer 2d data and this should
probably all be static to be honest so
let's just make that all static
since it lives inside here and is that
actually going to work
texture index yes that should be fine
renderer
2d data max indices
so if this is above our max indices
then we need to basically end first
so we'll do end scene we'll have to
um and this might be slightly
problematic because we don't copy the
camera but anyway we'll see
so end scene we need to do a flush i
think the flush happens by unseen
so we just basically do end scene and
then begin scene
except the only problem is we need the
camera to begin the scene
um so let's see what the let's see what
actually happens here so we bind the
textures and we do texture
i mean i guess technically speaking
we don't really need to do all of this
because um
[Music]
yeah i think what we'll do is we'll
actually come down here
we'll write a little private function
here
um and again this technically speaking
this doesn't have to be in here i guess
i'll
i'll leave it out because since we're
since we're not dealing with class
members ever
it can be completely private here so
what i'll do is i'll actually under
flush i'll make a static
void um this does feel a little bit
dirty though
but we'll say basically start new batch
and start new bash is going to leave a
lot of the state already intact for
example we don't need to reset the
camera
we don't need to um bind our texture
shader because it's it's already going
to be bound we're just starting a new
batch
what we really have to do is just reset
all of this stuff and like you know
and make sure that we obviously flush
and do all of that stuff
beforehand so start new batch um
will end the batch so
renderer yeah okay i'm actually not
going to do that because
i don't know we could keep it completely
private and enclosed but it's just
it's going to be a little bit
inconvenient i think
so start new batch um
i don't know if that's particularly a
descriptive name or not
but we'll leave it like this for now so
this is going to
end scene and then it's going to do this
so end scene obviously is going to copy
the data which i guess we should
probably bring out into its own function
so it makes more sense
but it's basically going to copy the
data to the quad vertex buffer
and then it's going to flush which is
going to render everything and increase
our draw calls and do all of that stuff
and then we're going to without
rebinding
the shader or resetting the projection
matrix
we're going to just reset this stuff
because that's the important stuff
um and then we're actually going to uh
yeah we'll continue on with everything
else so instead of doing end scene begin
scene we're just going to do us
we're just going to do start new batch
and that's it so yeah
i don't i can't say i'm 100 happy with
this because obviously we do have some
code that we're
repeating and if we add another kind of
uh variable that actually needs to be
um like reset or something like that
we're going to have to add it to both
begin
scene and also start new batch which
isn't which isn't great
um but yeah this is basically just going
to like flush and start a new batch
and again i i don't know with the name i
think
maybe we'll just call this flush and
reset
i think that may make more sense so
flush and reset will actually
end the scene and then reset everything
rather than start new bash so
that way if we read this and we see okay
if the data is above
max indices will flush and reset okay so
that's i think that's going to be fine
um okay so quad index count max indices
i think like that all of this should be
correct but you know we'll have to test
it out and
stuff because i am just writing this on
the fly
without having tested it first as usual
because you know me
um all right so we're adding these to
all the functions obviously
i think that's it um okay
so now what we're gonna do is
on i'm going render where we have our uh
square color
i'm going to add some which i don't
think we even use do we
m square color yeah that's old okay
whatever i'll still keep it around for
like
you know in case we want to use it again
i guess um what i'll do is i'll say
i'm gui text and we'll say
[Music]
renderer 2d stats
so we'll make a bunch of these and then
what i'll do is i'll have something like
um you know well we will have draw calls
let's see draw calls which will be
and then we have to get the stats
obviously so we'll do renderer
hazel renderer 2d uh
render 2d get stats
and just assign that to auto here
get stats and then we'll do stats dot
draw calls uh stats dot quads
pod count
um and then i'll make two more that's
that are just going to be
vertices and indices just for fun and we
can you know we can have memory used and
all of that stuff if we if we really
want so get total vertex account
and get um
[Music]
total index count as well
so this is again just before we reset
the stats that's
what it's going to show um okay let's
just try and run this so first of all
like this should not have affected
anything i think we should see the stats
obviously inside i am gooey but
in terms of rendering it should still be
fine and it is um
okay so if we expand this you can see
that we have five quads
one draw call 20 vertices 30 indices
okay makes sense to me so
now one of the things that i want to do
is say that our max size
is 2 and that way we can easily test
to see whether or not our limits and
like all the flushing like flush and
reset that we've added whether or not
that actually works so if i come over
here and i make max quads 2
okay which is quite fun um
i don't think we'd ever have this but uh
let's see if it works and you can see we
crash
so that's going to be interesting um
i wonder why we crashed so our index
count is 18 here
where do we crash exactly access
violation okay invalid value invalid
offset and or
size so this is good because this is us
testing like kind of edge cases i guess
even though this isn't really normal for
us to have this here it's still
very interesting so let's see what's
happened
so we okay so it's called flush and
reset obviously
and we're inside end scene now end scene
calls
flush what's the data size 528
that seems i guess that seems reasonable
528 i mean for what for two vertices
that does seem a little bit high 528
bytes
is everything is everything happening
correctly here it looks like it
quad vertex buffer base i guess we can
yeah 528
data size buffer pointer
we definitely reset that here
after end scene but we haven't actually
done that yet so we've tried to draw our
quad it's impossible to tell whether or
not
max indices is 12 index count is 18.
yeah because we've oh okay we i think we
have
i think we have an issue here um
uh yeah of course we have an issue here
my bad everything's fine it's just my
bad
so um we need to actually yeah we need
to do that
because uh it is exactly a multiple of
six
so we'll just add that in so let's see
because if we try and draw two this will
be twelve and so will the max indices
will be twelve quad index count will be
twelve that's twelve that means we can't
draw any more
um so i was just i was just just wrong
just flat out wrong
in the first in my first kind of
thinking
over here all right so let's just double
check all of these
uh where's this oh good i thought we
missed this function
okay good let's try that again so that
was fine that was just a crash inside
the driver because we overflowed our
vertex buffer
all right so we still draw everything
you can see now it's in three draw calls
right because we have five quads so
obviously if we have two quads per draw
max
five sounds right and then everything
else is here as well
which is good okay now let's try and
draw something a little bit more complex
just as a bit of a stress test and we'll
probably end the episode there
so what i'll do is um i might actually
even start a new scene
to make things more interesting not that
we need to
but we will because we want to test that
out and what we'll do is we'll
write a for loop maybe that
goes from like uh
let's see minus five y
maybe and we should try alpha blending
and there's a lot of stuff we need to
try
all the way up to five this isn't the
most efficient way of doing anything
really but whatever
um we'll increment this by 0.5 maybe
so that should give us what like 20
quads
on one axis we'll do the same for x
and i'm just going to draw a quad it's
not going to be rotated or anything
we'll just draw a normal quad
and then what do we have so position so
position we'll just do x y
now size now 0.5 is kind of our size i
want to have a little bit of a spacing i
guess between them so we'll do like 0.45
for the size
um and then what do we have here our
color
so the color what should we do with the
color
we can draw them all one color that may
be slightly boring
we could try and go with a gradient
so let's say float we'll go with a red
gradient so we'll say
the red color is going to be now it's
between negative five and five
but we probably want to um
i'll make this sorry i'll make this a
i'll actually make this a vector
so this is this is going to be our rg
red and green color maybe red and blue
so i don't like green
um we will say x will be red so we'll
say
x plus five divided by ten
right so what this will do is we'll
increment x by five meaning instead of
being negative now it's going to be in
about in a range between 0 and 10
and then we're dividing we're dividing
it by 10 to get it into the range of
0 and 1 which is what we want for our
color and then
for our y color um we will do
i might as well just call this color to
be honest i don't know why i'm making it
difficult for myself
uh green will keep on like point three
or point four maybe and then
the y axis so the vertical will be our
blue color so we should get a nice kind
of gradient
of like really probably green all the
way up to like purple or something
anyway that looks good i think um except
this is
this glm does not like my code
what's going on here arts effect 2 still
vec3 all right so now we have a color
except we also need uh actually needs to
be a vec4
so let's set this i don't know if
blending will work we can try it but
let's set it to one for now
so this is now our color
okay um and this isn't happy because
ah because i didn't put these inside
here
all right so now we should be drawing a
whole nother grid of
uh little squares and we are okay
so we have 203 draw calls now which
definitely is not very efficient
we have a whole grid um it looks i guess
it looks correct
i don't know it's hard to tell because
it looks a little bit crazy but yeah
there's our green all the way up to our
kind of purple slash pink
um we've got orange down here yeah it
looks looks decent um
let's maybe up this from like you know
203 draw calls let's
tell our bass renderer that we want to
maybe render it in
well let's try one draw calls let's
let's reset this back up to like well
we'll put up to twenty thousand
and then we'll see if that renders in
one draw called
red is in two draw calls really we have
more than how many quarters do we have
four hundred and five
oh okay that makes sense though because
we'll remember we're beginning
another scene we've got two scenes even
though they're technically the same
okay that looks good uh let's try and
blend them for fun we'll see if this
even works i have
i'm not really sure if it will
but let's check it out so for this we'll
set this select 0.5
and we may get some nice transparency
because we are rendering the grid first
and i expect well i mean it should work
yeah there it is
okay so we're getting properly alpha
blended sprites here which look pretty
good let's go ahead and just
make our grid larger though we'll start
to make this scene look
kind of half decent maybe so instead of
having enough um
all right well yeah we'll make this like
maybe
20 by 20 um and then we'll
make this from negative 10
we'll we'll change the anchor point to
negative 10 and then we should be
okay and by anchor point i mean the kind
of position all right so
looking at this
uh that did not seem to work at all
what's going on here because zero
the origin is the center right so
why is that not we're scaling it up 20
and we're translating at negative
10. i mean that probably should have
worked why is that not showing up in the
center everything else is right
i think it should be and of course this
is just another case of me being an
absolute idiot um because obviously if
zero is the middle you just leave it at
zero and you get the middle so that's
perfectly the middle now which is good
so we have this kind of large quad
texture which is like our backdrop and
then we have um
this nice uh kind of rendering you know
all of these
all this this gradient and we might even
up the alpha a little bit just to make
it look a bit
nicer maybe 0.7 here okay that's pretty
much it that's what i wanted to do today
so you can see that we can render
you know we could have rendered this in
one draw call clearly but we just chose
not to so we have two draw calls 405
quads
16 20 vertices and 24 30 indices being
rendered in
two draw calls now because we've
separated them into two scenes
um so just just as a little test if i
get rid of the end scene begin scene
then obviously uh this should just just
work yeah and you can see it's now one
draw call so that is good that's what we
want
um and then finally i guess one last
thing that i'll do is
i will change this to be just
you know so we have 400 quads let's make
it 100 quads per draw so this is a
little bit more
i guess realistic than two as a test not
that i expect this not to work because
we've tested pretty much everything else
yep we have five draw calls now
and finally as just a little fun thing
let's change this to one quad
per draw so now we should have 400 draw
calls 405 draw calls everything still
works everything still runs
pretty quick to be honest because you
know we're not really stressing it out
too much
and i guess fine we'll make it so that
we draw an absurd amount of quads
so let's go ahead and change this to
like point one
um and then we'll well still keep
everything the same
and i don't know if this will work or
not but i guess we're gonna see
um okay it is running very slowly so we
have two draw calls
at the moment we have one uh we have uh
ten thousand quads
and we have sixty one thousand vertices
sorry forty thousand vertices it is
running quite slow
though it might be because of all the
alpha blending um
although i don't really expect it to be
that
i don't think so i think it's most
likely all the math that we're doing
every single draw
yeah so um the best way to speed that up
would just be to try to do that in
release mode
and i think it will be good and then in
the future we can of course address that
and probably make it a bit more case
friendly and deal with that because
we definitely need like i don't know my
goal for this is to be able to draw
maybe like a hundred thousand quads
or something in a draw call at like 60
fps
um so yeah i mean it's it's it's running
super smooth now as you can see we're
drawing
10 000 quads in two draw calls um
super smooth uh so yeah it was probably
just all the mathematics
like all the adding and stuff that we
were doing for each vertex
um when we were running it
uh let's change this back when we were
doing it in debug mode
because that stuff will that stuff will
kill you if you're not using like sse
and all of this other stuff and
optimizations basically
all right cool so for our test two draw
calls 405 quads
everything looks pretty good next time
what i really want to do
is basically i guess maybe
incorporate some more textures get it to
i don't know
we could try build some kind of scene if
you guys have any suggestions
i'm obviously going to push this code
right now to github so
you'll be able to excuse me you'll be
able to
download this and maybe try and
construct some kind of scene if you so
desire
if you come up with anything interesting
then post it on discord
uh discord the channel.com discord is
how you can join that
if you're not in my discord server
there'll be a link in the description
below
there's a channel called game engine
series if you join that channel
then you can post what you've done there
and then maybe i'll select something
from there
if it's a cool kind of scene that i like
and i can check out your code and i can
integrate it and we can come up with
something so you can make like this huge
kind of scale tile map or something like
that like a little world
out of all these things and we can see
um if we can use that as a test case for
optimization
in the future if nothing comes out of
that then i will just make probably end
up making my own scene
and we'll uh do that in the next episode
anyway i want to thank you guys for
watching
this series as always patreon comments
showing us the best way to help support
everything that i'm doing here on
youtube
i've been doing live streams every
single week working on the 3d version of
hazel
and in fact i've been doing live streams
in general um
i there's a few complications with them
i want to start doing more public live
streams like for example last night
i was just like doing a a little bit of
lua investigation for hazel then we
played a bit of minecraft hardcore
and did stuff like that um i did that on
youtube but i'm probably going to do
that on twitch.tv
the churno for in the future as soon as
i get my internet upgraded because my
upload speed is absolutely terrible
but finally i can get better internet in
my area so that's happening
um but anyway sorry microphone that's
what's going on
i want to keep working on hazel uh and i
want to
like once we finish off with this
renderer 2d stuff i really want to take
this into the into the direction of
making maybe some kind of tool or an
entity component system
and then integrating lua as a scripting
language so that we can actually start
to build up that kind of
like flappy bird clone that i made as a
game or any game in general
thank you guys for watching i will see
you next time goodbye
[Music]
you